c'est pas ça arrive puisque on en a
parlé avec denis balbir qui parlant
c'est un peu différent parce qu'ils
aient pensé ne pas être à l'antenne
néanmoins les propos sont terribles
regardez je suis bien content pour ccpd
arrogant au match aller l'a commise
était sûr de gagner et de se dire
excusez moi bien sûr je condamne ce qui
vient dire laisse moi s'il vous plaît
ferme apparemment non je conçois qu'il
vient de dire je mets la clé hors
antenne et le problème à notre époque
aujourd'hui dès qu'on dit à un truc
l'emmène on le connaît pas dans
l'intimité
c'est l'arrêté quand je viens d'abord je
dois de chaudanne rachète deux choses
quand on est animateur télé je vous le
dis on a une clause tous où on s'engage
à ne pas avoir des propos insultants et
très différemment c'est une clause c'est
donc contre à sa caution faits sont
aussi on fait un mauvaise blague
si on fait un retour des choses qui sont
pas acceptables on est viré voilà donc
faut arrêter de dire des conneries
s'cusez moi il ya des choses qui se
disent pas même en rente haine parce que
c'est comme ça c'est un de ces petits
propos là que dans la rue il ya 30 ans
qui s'est cassé la gueule j'en ai marre
noah aux miss audard parce qu'on ne sait
pourquoi parce qu'on ne fait que mettre
de l'huile sur le feu et les jambes au
quotidien s'appuie sur la gueule et
franchement c'est ça mais je sais bien
mais on peut pas dire ça voilà je vous
le dis il faut que les mentalités
changent ça c'est denis balbir il n'a
pas 20 ans les gens qui nous écoutent
convainc 30 ans faut qu'il change ses
mentalités pour les phases avancer les
choses parce que ça cédait encore des
blagues de faire des blagues c'est
encore des expressions que nous que nos
parents disaient qu'ils on disait avant
là il faut savoir alors je défends pas
parce que de la même manière que j'ai
dit daniel bravo c'est pas bien là c'est
pas bien non plus sauf que denis balbir
ce jour-là il vit un drame fait je viens
retrouve les copains mais je savais que
mal mais quand j'ai commencé à la fin j
trust avait été honnête j'ai dit je
connais bras est ce que quand j'ai
commencé la phrase est ce que j'ai dit
de la même manière que c'est neil bravo
ce qu'a fait cet c'est pas bien denis
balbir c'est pas bien est-ce que j'ai
commencé ma phase en disant ça j'ai
commencé comme ça sauf que tu veux faire
ton cir alors fais ton ciel moi je dis
que là c'est des propos hors antenne
c'est grave aussi les uns les allemands
les commentateurs allemands avaient pas
arrêter d'embêter pendant tout le match
faisait partie de ces données
[Musique]
ok juste un dock est payant canal qui
s'appelle je dispose d'un solide qui a
mis en avant et en lumière tous ces
problèmes là qui était très bien fait
c'est pour ces raisons là pour faire
attention à ce qu'on dit qu'on soit à
l'antenne ou auront-elles et surtout
quand on est animateur télé sur regardes
et tu vois au stade tu fais des cris de
singe par le passé ça m'est arrivé
passato l'ofas on va dire que c'est fait
pour perturber le joueur mehdi propre
comme ça depuis la nuit des temps
tisser la couleur je cours ou le singe
et foncer il grimpe aux arbres
il fait plus alors on le répète
l'associé cette chose-là roues alors la
vienne arriver tôt ou tard vous vous
êtes à l'antenne externe
alors parce que j'aime pas et j'aime pas
ce truc de dire quand je dis que
quelqu'un a tort en l'occurrence denis
balbir gide ils avaient tort qu'on vient
de me dire ouais parce que c'est ton
papa sera l'acteur mois ils m'invitent
sur arte elle faire des émissions de
foot parce que je suis passionné de foot
c'est pas pour ça que c'est un pote
c'est comme ça que je veux rester avec
qui il traînait comme pour ça bon alors
quand on connaît les gens auxquels vous
avez pas compris quand je commence ma
phrase en disant on semblait la même
année avec congrès ni balbir la foulée
maîtrise très bon on a compris daniel
bravo
qu'est-ce qu'on vous ne le prenez pas
peur de rien mais on a compris la vallée
juste une chose on dit simplement une
chose simple simplement une chose simple
c'est très bien je dis trois fois le
même mot dans la même phrase tu quand on
est à l'antenne
hors antenne ou à l'en-tête équipe usée
quand on est animateur pour les
problèmes avant après c'est pas con
disant qu'ils vous regardent seul
fantasme c'est dit c'est pour ça que je
dis que les mentalités elle change
maintenant parce que ça à 20 ans il
fallait avant n'ont jamais su rebondir
que je souhaitais vraiment dans une des
choses qui qu'il a dit qu'avant c'est
que quand on fait des cris de singe
on est raciste à aucun débat quand on
dit pour un noir on est raciste
quand on dit espèce de l'open c'est de
[ __ ] c'est cmuh mentalité qu'il faut
arrêter avec ce genre de racisme un
passif mais ce créa qui n'est pas
homophobe et on sait ça vient
on disait c'est pas pour ça qu'on est
homophobe c'est pas pour ça qu'on est
homophobe c'est jean-michel ouais c'est
pour ça qu'on aime des pmp j'avais fait
une île isolée par voilà excuse parce
que on peut parler de tout on peut
s'engueuler mais surtout on s'aime